From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，您正在收听《美国生活》。
OK, so going down the stairs to walk the dog, reluctant to use the elevator today because there are explosions in my area, mostly pretty rare ones, but over the last hour, maybe more frequent.
好了，现在下楼去遛狗。今天不太想用电梯，因为我住的地区有爆炸声，平时很少见，但过去这一小时里，爆炸似乎变频繁了。
This is recorded in Kyiv by a woman named Katia. And it takes you into the everydayness of this war in this very intimate, three-dimensional way. I'm going to play you a bit more of this before I say more about it.
这段录音来自基辅，录音人是一位名叫卡蒂亚的女士。它以一种非常私密、立体的方式，带你走进了这场战争的日常。在深入讨论之前，我想让你再听听其中的片段。
And I already have noticed that the best way to know if they are really close is to observe the birds. If the birds start panicking and flying away, that means that explosion is probably relatively close.
我已经发现，判断它们（爆炸）是否真的很近，最好的办法是观察鸟类。如果鸟儿开始惊慌失措地飞走，那就说明爆炸可能相对较近了。
[EXPLOSION]
[爆炸声]
[ALARM]
[警报声]
Oh, here. There was another one. I really need to have my dog pee. There is a beep of the door.
哦，在这儿。又响了一声。我的狗真的得撒尿了。门那边有哔哔声。
[DOOR CREAKING]
[门嘎吱声]
[ALARM]
[警报声]
And so day, I think, second of the war-- I think it was February 25-- there was shooting that I could hear from three directions. And then when I came home, almost immediately I heard this loud, metallic noise. And I looked out the window, and there was a tank driving along my building. So there is a dig in the ground where Russian tank was driving, and my dog is considering peeing on it right now, which is frankly hilarious. But if you go along them, you can clearly see--
我想，在战争的第二天，也就是2月25日那天，我能听到来自三个方向的枪声。当我回到家时，几乎立刻就听到了一种巨大的金属撞击声。我往窗外看，看到一辆坦克正沿着我的楼房开过。地上有个坑，就是俄罗斯坦克开过的地方，我的狗现在正考虑在上面撒尿，这说实话挺滑稽的。但如果你沿着它们看，你能很清楚地看到——
OK, the birds are flying. I think I will try to head back in general direction of my house, and sorry. My dog is stubborn. He doesn't want to. I think he wants to go poop. Risking my life for you, asshole. No, he's not an asshole. He's a very sweet and kind dog. He is very, very calm about the-- OK, I'm going home because this one was really loud.
好吧，鸟儿在飞了。我想我还是尝试朝回家的方向走吧，抱歉。我的狗很固执，它不想走。我觉得它想拉屎。为了你，我简直是在冒生命危险，你这混蛋。不，它不是混蛋，它是一条非常可爱、善良的狗。它对……哦，我要回家了，因为这一声太响了。
Katia actually recorded these for the VICE News Reports podcast, starting at the beginning of the war. She asked that they and we not say her last name, or what part of the city she's in, or what kind of job she does, other than it's in education.
卡蒂亚其实是从战争一开始就为 VICE 新闻报道播客录制这些内容的。她要求我们以及她自己不要透露她的姓氏，也不要透露她所在的城市区域，或者她的工作内容，只说是教育行业的。
War is personal. We don't usually talk about it that way, but Ukraine had over 40 million people at the start of the war. And there are just all kinds of ways that they're going through it, on all sorts of front lines. For Katia, the front line has been a bunch of different things, but one of them is her decision to stay in Kyiv with her parents. Her dad's 87. Her mom's 73. Both have medical issues.
战争是个人的。我们通常不会这样谈论它，但在战争开始时，乌克兰有超过4000万人口。他们正以各种方式经历着这一切，在各种前线上。对卡蒂亚来说，前线包含了很多不同的事物，其中之一就是她决定留在基辅陪伴父母。她父亲87岁，母亲73岁。两人都有健康问题。
My dad has cancer. He's not treatable, basically not treatable anymore. He's also almost completely blind. And so he's basically lying in bed the entire day, apart from walking along the corridor a little bit and eating, and he's listening to radio. My mom has diabetes. She also has trouble walking. They are choosing to stay here because they can't just go to the bomb shelter back and forth all the time. And we're just hoping for the best.
我爸爸患有癌症。基本上已经无法治疗了，彻底没法治了。他几乎完全失明。所以他基本整天躺在床上，除了偶尔在走廊走一走、吃点东西，就是听广播。我妈妈患有糖尿病，走路也很困难。他们选择留在这里，因为他们没法一直反复去防空洞。我们只能祈求最好的结果。
She shops for them, stays up nights to help her dad with whatever he needs. At this stage of his illness, she says, he wouldn't be as comfortable anywhere as he is in this apartment. She does a bunch of different stuff in these audio diaries, like she does a tour of their apartment, which includes a stop at this big bag in the hallway with stuff that she's packed if they need to flee.
她为他们采购生活用品，熬夜照顾父亲的一切需求。她说，在他患病的这个阶段，比起在这个公寓里，他在任何地方都不会感到那么舒适。她在这些音频日记里记录了很多琐事，比如她给公寓做了一次导览，其中包括走到走廊里的那个大背包前，那是她为逃难准备的物品。
Inside my backpack, I have documents. I have some of my clothes, headlight. I think I have some of my underpants. OK, going further through my corridor, there is a spot where I sleep because it has wall on one hand and it has a big wardrobe on the other. I think it's, maybe apart from the bathroom, the best option to survive in case of blast.
背包里装有证件。我还放了一些衣服、头灯。我想我还有些内裤。好吧，继续沿着走廊走，这里有个地方是我睡觉用的，因为一边有墙，另一边有个大衣柜。我想，除了浴室，这是防爆情况下生存的最佳选择。
There's an audio diary that she does, where her dad is listening to a radio report, where people on the radio are explaining what taxes they do and do not need to pay right now that the country is in a state of war. There's one where Katia notes that before the war, the hallway in her apartment building always smelled like weed because that's where teenagers went to get high, but that hasn't been true since the war. And then she records this one, I guess, for her American listeners.
她有一篇音频日记是录下她父亲听广播报道的场景，广播里的人在解释国家处于战时状态下，人们需要缴纳和不需要缴纳哪些税。还有一篇日记里，卡蒂亚提到战前公寓大楼的走廊里总是有大麻味，因为那是青少年吸食的地方，但战争开始后就再也没闻到过了。然后她录下了下面这段，我想，是录给她的美国听众听的。
OK, there is an address by the president that was published exactly three minutes ago. So I'm going to watch it.
好吧，总统刚刚在三分钟前发表了讲话。所以我打算去看一下。
[SPEAKING UKRAINIAN]
[乌克兰语讲话]
I know that Zelensky is a bit of a sex symbol in the West right now, so I hope this is a bit of an ASMR sesh for you, [LAUGHS] as well.
我知道泽连斯基现在在西方被视为某种性象征，所以我希望这对你们来说也能是一次 ASMR（颅内高潮）体验，[笑]也是。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I'm sorry if this was way too harsh of a joke.
如果这个玩笑开得太过了，我很抱歉。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
[SPEAKING UKRAINIAN]
[乌克兰语讲话]
Katia's dog, Yoki, is in a bunch of these audio diary entries. In one of them, she talks about how they bought some canned dog food for him, which luckily he likes. He's apparently kind of a finicky eater. But now the cans are running out, and they're not sure what they're going to find to replace them with.
卡蒂亚的狗 Yoki 出现在多篇音频日记中。其中一篇里，她谈到他们给它买了些罐装狗粮，幸运的是它喜欢吃。它显然是个挑食的家伙。但现在罐头快吃完了，他们不确定能找到什么来替代。
Today we gave him one can in the morning, and in the evening my mom said that maybe we should don't give him his second meal to spread out the food supplies for him that we have. And my dad, he just wanted to eat kefir, which I don't know if you're familiar with. It's a kind of sour milk drink. He drank maybe half of it, maybe a little bit more than half of it, and he just said, give the rest to the dog. And this was heartbreaking. My 87-year-old dad, him in his condition, he'd given half of his dinner to the dog. It's just fucked. Russian warship, go fuck yourself.
今天早上我们给了它一罐，晚上我妈妈说或许我们不该给它第二顿饭，以便节省我们现有的食物储备。而我爸爸，他只想喝开菲尔（一种酸奶饮品），不知道你们熟不熟悉。他大概喝了一半，或者稍微多一点，他就说，把剩下的给狗吧。这真是令人心碎。我87岁的父亲，以他那种身体状况，竟然把晚餐的一半给了狗。这真是太糟糕了。俄罗斯战舰，去死吧。
In a war, the front line is everywhere, every place the war touches. And right now, people are navigating their own small struggles in the shadow of this huge one. In putting together today's show, I thought about Studs Terkel's book, The Good War. I don't know if you know this one. He tries to document World War II, but not talking about it as history with a capital H, but just, he does interviews, just these great interviews with all sorts of people who lived through the war. Today's show is kind of like that. Anyway, stay with us.
在战争中，前线无处不在，战争所触及的每一个地方都是。现在，人们正在这巨大的苦难阴影下，处理着各自的小挣扎。在策划今天的节目时，我想到了 Studs Terkel 的书《好战》（The Good War）。不知道你们知不知道这本书。他试图记录二战，但不是将其作为大写的历史来谈论，而是通过采访，与那些亲历战争的各色人等进行伟大的交谈。今天的节目也类似。无论如何，请留下来。
Act One, Yevgenia and Her Neighbors. So one of the things that made us want to do a show of personal stories in this war was reading these diaries that Yevgenia Belorusets has been publishing. She's a writer and a photographer in Kyiv. And after the Russians invaded, when she'd go out and take pictures, she would be told over and over to put away her camera. People wanted to know, are you a spy? They didn't want to be photographed. So instead she started writing about the interactions that she was having with people and putting them into Der Spiegel Magazine.
第一幕，叶夫根尼娅和她的邻居们。我们想要做一期关于战争中个人故事的节目的原因之一，是读到了叶夫根尼娅·别洛鲁塞茨（Yevgenia Belorusets）一直在发表的日记。她是基辅的一位作家和摄影师。俄军入侵后，每当她出门拍照，就会被人一遍又一遍地要求收起相机。人们想知道，你是间谍吗？他们不想被拍照。于是，她开始撰写自己与人们的互动，并将这些内容发布在《明镜周刊》上。
Kyiv was nowhere as violent or as dangerous as certain other cities in Ukraine, but everybody was still living in this city that was transformed by the war and figuring out how to deal with that. In the diaries, Yevgenia says over and over in different ways, is this really happening? Even just a week or two into the war, she writes about how it feels like it's been going on forever. She gave us permission to excerpt the diaries here. They're read first by actress Ivanna Sakhno. They begin on February 24, the day of the invasion, day one, and then proceed day by day, day two, day three, which is where we'll pick them up.
基辅远没有乌克兰其他城市那样暴力或危险，但每个人仍生活在这座被战争改变的城市里，摸索着如何应对。在日记中，叶夫根尼娅一遍又一遍地以不同方式问道，这一切是真的吗？甚至在战争刚开始一两周时，她就写道，感觉战争已经持续了很久很久。她授权我们在这里摘录这些日记。首先由演员伊万娜·萨赫诺（Ivanna Sakhno）朗读。日记从入侵第一天（2月24日）开始，逐日推进，直到我们要切入的第三天。
Day three, my first night in a bomb shelter. It is 1 and 1/2 floors deep underground, to be precise, a network of corridors and corridors. At the dark entrance to our basement, I see the silhouettes of residents scurrying past each other. You can overhear the occasional petty arguments. Two older shadows pass by two younger ones. Good evening. But the evening is not good, the younger ones protest. We wish you a good evening anyway, the older ones say in triumphant tone, because we mean well and we'll continue to wish it. The shadows disappear into the depths of the cellar.
第三天，我在防空洞的第一夜。准确地说，是在地下1.5层，这里是一个走廊交错的网络。在阴暗的地下室入口处，我看到居民们匆匆走过的身影。你能听到偶尔的琐碎争吵。两个年长的身影从两个年轻的身影旁走过。晚上好。但年轻人反驳道，晚上并不好。老人们以一种胜利者的口吻说，不管怎样，我们还是祝你们晚上好，因为我们出于好意，并将继续保持这份心意。身影消失在地下室的深处。
As I write, it occurs to me that during the day, I saw many smiling people, for example, a woman who was sitting in the park, on a bench, next to two shopping bags. She spoke to me in an absurdly happy voice, saying that she was waiting for her nephew to help her carry the bags home. I'm so happy to have you standing next to me now, talking to me. When there are two of us, I'm less afraid of the artillery.
我在写作时突然想到，白天我看到许多面带微笑的人，比如一位女士坐在公园的长椅上，身旁放着两个购物袋。她以一种荒诞快乐的声音告诉我，她正在等侄子帮她把袋子拎回家。我很高兴你现在站在我身边和我说话。当我们有两个人时，我对炮火的恐惧就少了一些。
Day five. Almost all pharmacies are closed. Electricity, water, and heating are under constant threat of failure. The public spaces, squares, streets in the city are empty. I accompanied a German friend who could not stay in Kyiv to the railway depot, a journey of 25 minutes, which for me was a walk into another vast reality. Since the beginning of the war, I have not visited Shevchenko Boulevard, a wide street leading down to the depot. We walked along the street, and every house, every intersection, carried something new, a new language, a new narrative about our shared reality. The city looked peaceful. We quickly said goodbye and I strolled back alone.
第五天。几乎所有的药店都关门了。电力、自来水和暖气随时面临断供的威胁。城市里的公共空间、广场和街道空无一人。我陪一位无法留在基辅的德国朋友去火车站，那是一段25分钟的路程，对我来说，这就像是走进了另一个广阔的现实。自战争开始以来，我还没去过舍甫琴科大道，那是一条通往车站的宽阔街道。我们走在街上，每一栋房子、每一个路口都带来了新的东西——一种新的语言，一段关于我们共同现实的新叙述。城市看起来很平静。我们匆匆道别，我独自踱步走回。
At about the same time, peaceful residents of the city of Berdiansk in the south of the country were gathered in front of their local government building, which was occupied by Putin's army and guarded by armed soldiers. The women shouted at the soldiers in Russian. How can you look your mothers in the face? You brought war and slaughter into our land. Shame on you. Old people were also in the crowd. They were not afraid.
大约在同一时间，南部别尔江斯克市的和平居民聚集在当地政府大楼前，那里被普京的军队占领，并由武装士兵看守。女人们用俄语向士兵喊道：你们怎么好意思面对你们的母亲？你们把战争和屠杀带到了我们的土地上。你们真丢脸。人群中也有老人。他们并不害怕。
The soldiers looked demoralized. They replied, we came to protect you. The women resisted. They continued to protest. We were never in danger here. There was no threat to us before you came. Now, with you, because of you, we are in the greatest danger. Then came cursed insults, which have a very great richness in the Ukrainian and Russian languages.
士兵们看起来士气低落。他们回答说，我们是来保护你们的。女人们反抗着，继续抗议。在我们这里从未有过危险。在你们来之前，我们没有受到任何威胁。现在，因为你们，我们正处于最大的危险之中。随之而来的是诅咒和谩骂，在乌克兰语和俄语中都有着极其丰富的词汇。
Day six. It is the sixth day of the war, which I feel has already lasted 50 years. I went for a walk to breathe some fresh air in this first day of spring and maybe do some shopping. Knowing that many supermarket shelves were already empty, I decided to visit a larger grocery store that had recently opened not far from us. How pleasant it was to be there. The shopping mall is deep underground. Everyone felt safe and walked past the shelves with a slowness that has not been seen in Kyiv for six days.
第六天。这是战争的第六天，我感觉它已经持续了50年。为了在春天这一天呼吸新鲜空气，也许是顺便买点东西，我出门散步。我知道许多超市货架已经空了，决定去一家离我们不远、最近刚开业的大型杂货店看看。那里让人感到惬意。购物中心位于地下。每个人都感到安全，走在货架旁的速度是基辅六天来未曾见过的。
On the way back, I took a picture of an old man sitting alone on a bench in the park. He wanted to talk to me. His wife was ill, he told me, and he was taking care of her. He wanted to take care of her until tomorrow. Then he will join the Kyiv territorial defense. He and his wife are 66 years old. In his youth, he served in the military. I started thanking him. I couldn't stop, as if that would prevent this elderly man, caring for his sick wife, from risking his life.
回来的路上，我给坐在公园长椅上的一位老人拍了张照。他想跟我说话。他告诉我他妻子病了，他在照顾她。他想再照顾她一天。明天，他就要加入基辅国土防卫队。他和妻子都66岁了。他年轻时服过兵役。我开始感谢他。我停不下来，仿佛这样就能阻止这位照顾病妻的老人去冒生命危险。
Day nine. I woke up quite early in a bright mood and with the feeling that this sunny day had something to offer me. Little was left of the melancholy I felt yesterday. Then I discovered the reason for this change. I no longer believe in the war. It simply can't be, I thought. It isn't true. What neighboring country bombs a city to rubble in the 21st century? You can't occupy this country. It's unrealistic. The war is a dream, a dictator's fantasy.
第九天。我起得很早，心情明亮，感觉这个晴天能给我带来些什么。昨天的忧郁已消散大半。然后我发现了心情改变的原因。我不相信战争的存在。我想，这简直不可能。这不是真的。21世纪，哪个邻国会把一座城市轰炸成废墟？你不可能占领这个国家。这不现实。战争是一场梦，一个独裁者的幻想。
I wanted to see if the little store next to our house still had bread. I have not been able to get bread since the third day of the war. It is usually sold out. The store was full. With some amazement, I discovered a group, who I took to be representatives of the International Military. They spoke English and needed help translating. Then I realized that they were not soldiers, but unarmed, if well-protected, escorts of a war photographer, who was also shopping in the store. I tried to help her choose a detergent.
我想看看屋旁的小店还有没有面包。自战争第三天起我就没买到过面包。通常都卖光了。店里挤满了人。令我惊讶的是，我发现了一群人，我以为他们是国际军事代表。他们说英语，需要翻译帮助。后来我才意识到，他们不是士兵，而是未携带武器但受到严密保护的一位战地摄影师的随行人员，摄影师也在店里购物。我试着帮她挑选洗涤剂。
The small group exuded enthusiasm, humor, and inspiration. My mood suddenly darkened. One of the three escorts proudly said to me, do you know who you're standing with? This is one of the best photographers in the world. And the photographer laughed and shrugged it off. Please, she said. I'm embarrassed. Then she told me her name. I can't remember the name. I've been having a hard time concentrating lately. Then she said, you can follow me on Instagram.
这群小团队散发着热情、幽默和灵感。我的心情突然沉了下去。其中一位随行人员骄傲地对我说：你知道你和谁站在一起吗？这是世界上最好的摄影师之一。摄影师笑了笑，耸耸肩说：求你了，别这样，我很尴尬。然后她告诉我她的名字。我不记得了，我最近很难集中注意力。然后她说，你可以在 Instagram 上关注我。
The group bought a lot of detergent, almost everything in the store. I told them, good to have you with us, and said, goodbye. But quickly, an uneasiness came over me. I realized that it is not a good sign when a well-known war photographer sets up shop here.
这群人买了很多洗涤剂，几乎把店里的货扫空了。我对他们说，很高兴有你们在，然后说再见。但很快，一种不安感袭上心头。我意识到，当一位著名的战地摄影师在这里安营扎寨时，这可不是什么好兆头。
Day 12. I receive a utility bill for my Kyiv apartment. It is accompanied by a telegram message that sounds like an apology. We are writing to you with a request. If your financial means allow, under the circumstances, please pay the utilities. Many Kyiv utility workers joined the Ukrainian army and are now fighting for our freedom. However, it is still important to pay the bills.
第12天。我收到了基辅公寓的账单。附带的电报信息听起来像是一种道歉：我们写信给你是有一个请求。如果经济条件允许，在目前情况下，请缴纳水电费。许多基辅的公用事业工人加入了乌克兰军队，正在为我们的自由而战。然而，支付账单仍然很重要。
Day 17. It was a sleepless night. The air raid alarm, sounding its sirens over the city, kept me up all night. I was too tired to go to the shelter. I heard explosions and hoped that no one was injured. My plan for the day was to pick up my bulletproof vest, which had finally been delivered. Then I would visit a lady who, as a sort of concierge, watches over a house in the neighborhood and keeps an eye on the comings and goings.
第17天。这是一个不眠之夜。空袭警报在城市上空鸣响，让我整晚无法入眠。我太累了，不想去避难所。我听到爆炸声，希望没人受伤。我当天的计划是去取终于寄到的防弹背心。然后我会去拜访一位住在附近、负责照看房子的女士，她就像一位看门人，留意着邻里的动静。
There are many such concierges in the city, but since the beginning of the war, this lady had taken on an additional task. She must make sure that nothing is stolen from the abandoned apartments. Her name had a comforting ring to it that reminded me of childhood-- Dussia.
城里有许多这样的看门人，但自战争开始以来，这位女士承担了额外的任务。她必须确保废弃的公寓里什么东西都不会被偷。她的名字听起来有一种令人安慰的、让人想起童年的感觉——杜西亚（Dussia）。
One of the residents from her building, who had escaped, had asked me to check in on her, which made her happy. Because she is alone, no one can relieve her of her watch. She also lives in the building where she works.
她所在大楼的一位已经逃离的住户曾拜托我去看望她，这让她很高兴。因为她孤身一人，没有人能分担她的值守工作。她也住在她工作的这栋楼里。
I visited her in her small concierge room on the first floor. There was only space for a table and a sofa. The TV was on. She said, so many people are escaping Kyiv, but I have nowhere to go. In her face I saw helplessness, but she had made her decision to stay put. I tried to lighten the mood with some not entirely clever jokes. I was happy that she smiled at me, and I decided to visit her again soon.
我在一楼她的小看门室里拜访了她。空间只够放一张桌子和一张沙发。电视开着。她说，好多人都在逃离基辅，但我无处可去。从她的脸上我看到了无助，但她已经决定留守原地。我试着用一些不太高明的笑话来缓解气氛。我很高兴她对我笑了，我决定很快再去探望她。
Day 24. Today an old couple made their way through the wreckage on Sich Riflemen's Street. They walked shakily past shards of broken glass and heaps of rubble. This elderly pair, who have lived their lives amid undying declarations of love between Russians and Ukrainians, two brotherly peoples, did not want to believe that fratricide was in full swing.
第24天。今天，一对老夫妻走过“射手大街”（Sich Riflemen’s Street）的残骸。他们摇摇晃晃地走过碎玻璃和瓦砾堆。这对老人曾生活在俄乌两国“兄弟民族”永恒的爱之宣言中，他们不愿相信同室操戈正在全面上演。
The man, speaking to his wife, reproached an invisible enemy. Look how many windows, how much glass has been smashed. Jesus. They haven't thought about the fact that they'll have to clean this up. All this chaos, just to say, the Russians did it to us. The man spoke desperately and with an honest sadness. The woman nodded and sighed. They walked straight past me.
那位男士对妻子说话，指责着一个看不见的敌人：看看有多少窗户，多少玻璃碎了。天哪，他们没想过他们得清理这些。所有这些混乱，就为了说：是俄罗斯人对我们干的。男士说话时充满绝望和真诚的悲伤。女人点了点头，叹了口气。他们从我身边直直走过。
On the ground, pigeons pecked at bread crumbs among the shards of glass. Despite the damage, a woman had come to the marketplace, as she does every day, to feed the birds. It was sunny and awfully quiet. The streets felt free. And there was a deceptive illusion that a long walk was safe.
在地上，鸽子在碎玻璃中啄食面包屑。尽管破坏严重，一位女士还是像往常一样来到市场喂鸟。阳光明媚，出奇地安静。街道感觉很自由。有一种错觉，仿佛长时间散步是安全的。
Day 26. I went to the train station with my mother to see if we could get train tickets for ourselves and our relatives. We walked through the old city that my mother had once shown me, like a story one reads to a child. The train station was not as crowded as we expected. All the shops had closed, and the only tickets available were for the evacuation trains. Several of these tickets were standing room only. And because some of my relatives have health concerns that keep them from standing, we decided to look for tickets again later.
第26天。我和妈妈去了火车站，看看能不能为我们和亲戚买到火车票。我们穿过老城，妈妈曾经像给孩子讲故事一样向我介绍过那里。火车站并不像我们预期的那么拥挤。所有的商店都关门了，唯一的车票是撤离列车的。其中一些票是站票。因为我的一些亲戚有健康问题不能站立，我们决定过会儿再找票。
My mother and I walked back down the street and tried to cheer each other up with a few jokes. Then we saw little yellow buses with red crosses, heading toward us in the direction of the train station. On each bus was written, Irpin, a place north of Kyiv where so many artists and writers once lived, and where now people die every day. Russia is annihilating the small town, block by block. In the dusty bus windows we saw the gray, tired faces of old people and children, all staring somewhere far away into the distance. We stopped and looked. I could not take a photo.
我和妈妈走回街上，试着用几个笑话让彼此振作起来。然后，我们看到一辆辆红色十字架的小黄色公交车朝着我们火车站的方向驶来。每辆车上都写着“伊尔平”（Irpin），那是基辅以北的一个地方，那里曾居住着许多艺术家和作家，而现在人们每天都在死去。俄罗斯正在逐个街区地消灭这座小镇。在积满灰尘的公交车窗里，我们看到了老人和孩子灰暗、疲惫的面孔，所有人都茫然地盯着远方。我们停下来看。我没法拍照。
In the evening, I saw that the train tickets were being sold again. Without much time to consider it, I bought six tickets for Friday. My parents still don't want to leave Kyiv. I really don't know what we should do, but there should be enough time before Friday to decide.
晚上，我看到火车票又开始发售了。来不及多考虑，我买了六张周五的票。我父母还是不想离开基辅。我真的不知道该怎么办，但在周五之前应该还有足够的时间来决定。
Day 29. A little girl looked at me with a friendly expression. She was coloring the backrest of a wooden bench with a piece of chalk. She tried to tell me something, but she was interrupted by her grandfather, who seemed annoyed. Listen here, he said to me in a somewhat brazen voice. I told my daughter, let's buy the apartment in Kyiv. But she replied, nobody wants to live in Kyiv, with its stuffy, big-city air. We should get a nice apartment under the green trees in Bucha, outside of Kyiv. And being the foolish person I am, I agreed. He looked at me reproachfully, as if I were the one who had persuaded him to buy an apartment in a pleasant suburb now smothered in fire, rockets, and mortar shells.
第29天。一个小女孩友好地看着我。她用粉笔在长椅的靠背上涂色。她想告诉我什么，但被她祖父打断了，他看起来很恼火。他对我说，语气有点蛮横：听着。我跟女儿说，让我们在基辅买套公寓吧。但她回答说，谁想住在基辅啊，空气又闷又拥挤。我们应该去基辅郊外布查（Bucha）的绿树下买套好公寓。我当时真是个傻瓜，竟然同意了。他责备地看着我，好像是我劝他去买一套现在被火海、火箭弹和迫击炮淹没的舒适郊区公寓一样。
I didn't even want to talk to him at first, but he called out to me and asked to walk a few steps in his direction. It was already evening. Soon the curfew would begin. The air raid alarm had just sounded, and I thought I only had a few minutes for a little conversation. But then the man mentioned Bucha, and all of a sudden, I decided to spend as much time with them as they wanted.
我起初甚至不想和他说话，但他叫住我，要求朝他的方向走几步。天已经晚了。宵禁很快就要开始。空袭警报刚刚响过，我以为我只有几分钟的时间谈话。但当那个男人提到布查时，我突然决定尽可能多花些时间和他们待在一起。
The girl, who was about six years old, told me in a serious voice, for two weeks we lived in the basement. We were 21 adults and seven children. The grandfather still seemed angry with me. I come from a city where most people speak Russian. I come from Dnipro, but part of our family lives here in Bucha and in Kyiv.
那个大约六岁的小女孩严肃地告诉我：我们在地下室住了两周。我们有21个成年人和7个孩子。祖父似乎还在生我的气。我来自一个大多数人说俄语的城市。我来自第聂伯罗，但我们家的一部分人住在这里，在布查和基辅。
Two weeks in the basement, with only water, some food, almost no heating, and barely any electricity, constant shelling, especially when we tried to sneak a little fresh air. And then they found us. The Russians came to us in the cellar and explained-- no, they barked-- that they had come to denazify us. If I were not 70 years old, I answered them, I would rather throw you out than talk to you. Don't speak to me, not even for a second.
两周的地下室生活，只有水和一点食物，几乎没有暖气，电力也很少，炮火不断，特别是当我们试图溜出去呼吸新鲜空气时。然后他们找到了我们。俄罗斯人冲进地窖，解释说——不，他们吼道——他们来是要把我们“去纳粹化”。我回答他们，如果我不是70岁了，我宁愿把你们赶出去也不愿和你们说话。别跟我说话，哪怕一秒钟也别。
At the end, he got so furious that he said to me, you should go there, to Bucha. If you were there, you wouldn't look at me like that. You would understand everything. And here in Kyiv, nothing has been made clear.
最后，他愤怒到了极点，对我说：你应该去那里，去布查。如果你在那里，你就不会那样看着我了。你会明白一切的。而在基辅，什么都没搞清楚。
Today my childhood friend lost his family home. Early in life, I used to visit his house all the time. I tried to remember the rooms. I recall the traditional living room of a small house with a low ceiling, a resplendent cabinet with old photos behind a glass shelf, and the meals my friend's grandmother used to prepare for us. This memory is not accompanied by any feeling.
今天，我儿时的朋友失去了他的家。早年间，我经常去他家玩。我试着回忆那些房间。我记得那间带有低矮天花板的传统客厅，柜门后摆着旧照片的闪亮柜子，还有朋友祖母为我们做的饭菜。这段记忆没有任何感觉。
Day 30. My relatives want to leave Kyiv. We had already planned our exit, but as the day of departure ruthlessly approached, they had more and more complaints and objections. Here in Kyiv, where every day you come across friends, acquaintances, and strangers you end up helping, you manage somehow to bear the unbearable news and events. We decided to postpone our departure for a few days and perhaps prepare a little better.
第30天。我的亲戚想离开基辅。我们已经计划好了离开，但随着出发日期无情地临近，他们有了越来越多的抱怨和异议。在这里，在基辅，每天你都会遇到朋友、熟人和需要帮助的陌生人，你总能设法承受那些难以忍受的消息和事件。我们决定推迟几天离开，也许准备得更好一点。
On the way back from the train station, my mother and I met two people from the military who were sitting in front of a grocery store, drinking coffee. They showed us a picture of a boy who was only 14 years old, posing in a uniform next to some soldiers.
从火车站回来的路上，我和妈妈遇到了两名坐在杂货店前喝咖啡的军人。他们给我们看了一张照片，那是一个只有14岁的男孩，身穿制服，和士兵们站在一起。
We're going to our military positions today to fetch him, one of the soldiers explained. He followed his father and wants to fight shoulder-to-shoulder with him, but he's too young. They have clearly lost everything, their house, their family, and now all he wants is to fight. We understand, of course, but cannot allow it. They were obviously proud, both of this mission and this boy's determination. They smiled with a little bit of tenderness, and their good mood even infected us.
其中一名士兵解释说：我们今天要去军事阵地接他。他跟随父亲，想与父亲并肩作战，但他太年轻了。他们显然失去了一切，房子、家庭，现在他一心只想战斗。我们当然理解，但不能允许。他们显然为这次任务和这个男孩的决心感到自豪。他们带着一丝温柔笑了笑，他们的好心情甚至感染了我们。
Ivanna Sakhno, reading the diaries of Yevgenia Belorusets. She got out of Ukraine on day 41, April 4. We first saw her diaries on the website, Isolarii. Yevgenia's diary is being published as part of a new book called In The Face of War. You can find links to all of that, as well as to some of Yevgenia's photography, at our website, ThisAmericanLife.org.
伊万娜·萨赫诺朗读叶夫根尼娅·别洛鲁塞茨的日记。她在第41天（4月4日）离开了乌克兰。我们最早是在 Isolarii 网站上看到的她的日记。叶夫根尼娅的日记作为新书《面对战争》（In The Face of War）的一部分正在出版。您可以在我们的网站 ThisAmericanLife.org 上找到所有相关链接，以及叶夫根尼娅的一些摄影作品。
Coming up, so your friend's a Russian soldier being sent into Ukraine. What do you say to him, exactly? It's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，如果你的朋友是个被派往乌克兰的俄罗斯士兵，你到底该对他说什么？稍后回来，节目将继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Other Front Lines, stories of the many ways that people are going through the war in Ukraine. We have arrived at Act Two of our program, Act Two, Munachi and the Escape.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天的节目《其他前线》，讲述人们在乌克兰经历战争的多种方式。我们现在进入节目的第二幕：穆纳奇（Munachi）和逃离。
So for years before this war, Ukraine had been a destination for foreign students, kids from Nigeria, Morocco, China, Azerbaijan, Turkey, India. The tuition is affordable. It's relatively easy to get a visa. You can study in English. So when the war started, 77,000 foreign students, just a ton of people, had to figure out what to do.
在战争前多年，乌克兰一直是外国学生的目的地，孩子们来自尼日利亚、摩洛哥、中国、阿塞拜疆、土耳其、印度。学费负担得起，签证容易办理，还可以用英语学习。所以当战争开始时，77000名外国学生——人数相当多——不得不思考该怎么办。
Alexis Okeowo is a reporter who was based in Lagos for a few years, and over the last few weeks, they've been hearing about Nigerian students trapped in Ukraine, Black students blocked at the border, unable to escape to the rest of Europe. Alexis also knew what an education in Ukraine had meant to those students. For lots of them, it was their one chance to get a degree. Back home in Nigeria, there aren't nearly enough seats in schools for everybody who wants them. If you do get in, your studies can be interrupted by long teacher strikes. Alexis wanted to talk to the students about what they were going through.
亚历克西斯·奥基沃（Alexis Okeowo）是一位曾在拉各斯工作几年的记者，过去几周，他们一直在听到有关被困在乌克兰的尼日利亚学生、被挡在边境无法逃往欧洲其他地方的黑人学生的消息。亚历克西斯也知道在乌克兰接受教育对这些学生意味着什么。对他们中的许多人来说，这是获得学位的唯一机会。在老家尼日利亚，学校名额远不够所有人使用。即使能入学，学习也可能因长期的教师罢工而中断。亚历克西斯想和这些学生聊聊他们的遭遇。
Over the last month, as I read about the racism international students-- especially African ones-- were facing as they tried to leave Ukraine, I felt angry, and sad, and curious. Who were these kids caught in a war, and what had their lives been like in Ukraine? What would they be now?
过去一个月，当我读到国际学生——尤其是非洲学生——在试图离开乌克兰时所面临的种族歧视时，我感到愤怒、悲伤且好奇。这些被困在战争中的孩子是谁？他们在乌克兰的生活是什么样的？现在又会如何？
When I went to Ukraine, it was a very beautiful place. It was like everything is organized.
当我来到乌克兰时，这是一个非常美丽的地方。一切都井井有条。
This is Munachi Nnadi. He arrived in Ukraine last summer. Munachi is someone at ease with himself, gentle, the really big smile. And he's a person who likes to plan things to be in order. For instance, one thing he mentioned that he first noticed in Ukraine was how the cars were parked in straight lines. Out of all the Nigerian students I spoke with, Munachi had the most clarity about what he wanted to do with his life and why he was in Ukraine. He wanted to be a doctor and then work in the United States, the UK, or Switzerland.
这是穆纳奇·纳迪（Munachi Nnadi）。他去年夏天来到乌克兰。穆纳奇是一个随和、温柔、脸上挂着灿烂笑容的人。他喜欢把事情规划得井井有条。例如，他提到在乌克兰最先注意到的一点是汽车是如何排成直线停放的。在他谈到的所有尼日利亚学生中，穆纳奇对自己的人生目标以及为何身在乌克兰有着最清晰的规划。他想成为一名医生，然后在美国、英国或瑞士工作。
When Munachi landed in Ukraine, a Nigerian representative from his new university picked him up. They played Bob Marley as they drove through the city.
穆纳奇抵达乌克兰时，一位来自他新学校的尼日利亚代表接了他。车上播放着鲍勃·马利的音乐，载着他穿过城市。
And it was so beautiful, like the different people, the color and everything, the waterfalls. Ah, it was so beautiful, like new things to me.
那里真美，不同的人、色彩还有一切，还有瀑布。啊，真是太美了，对我来说一切都是新的。
A lot of things were new. Munachi managed to get an apartment with other Nigerians in the southern city of Odessa, but he didn't know where to exchange money. A friend invited him to join a group chat on Telegram called Nigerian Students Ukraine. It's a big group. Over 1,000 Nigerians are in it.
很多东西都是新的。穆纳奇成功在南部的敖德萨市和其他尼日利亚人合租了一套公寓，但他不知道去哪里换钱。一个朋友邀请他加入了一个名为“乌克兰尼日利亚学生”的 Telegram 群组。这是一个大群，里面有超过1000名尼日利亚人。
Reading through the messages, I was reminded they're college students, trying to learn how to be adults. They're just kids, even though Munachi doesn't like me to call him that. Members helped each other find jobs and Nigerian restaurants. Do you have dollars and you need grivna? DM me. Who's in for a shared apartment in Kharkiv? Abeg oo. If you're looking for an unserious relationship, please just DM me. Single ladies only. Me. Job needed in Kharkiv. Anyone available or knows anyone to help, please? Are you interested in a modeling shoot in Kyiv? Please send your picture for number and age if you're interested.
读着这些信息，我提醒自己他们只是大学生，正在学习如何成为成年人。他们还是孩子，尽管穆纳奇不喜欢我叫他孩子。群成员们互相帮忙找工作和尼日利亚餐厅。“你有美元需要换格里夫纳吗？私信我。”“谁想在哈尔科夫合租公寓？拜托了。”“如果你在找一段不严肃的关系，请私信我。仅限单身女性。”“我。”“哈尔科夫急需工作。有人有资源或认识谁能帮忙吗？”“有兴趣在基辅拍摄模特照吗？如果你感兴趣，请发送你的照片、号码和年龄。”
Munachi settled in, started learning Ukrainian. I asked him what he did for fun.
穆纳奇安定下来，开始学习乌克兰语。我问他平时做什么消遣。
[SIGHING]
[叹气]
Well, actually, to be honest, the parts I enjoy most is being in school. Yeah, being in school and doing what I love. I love anatomy. That's my favorite. It's very interesting. Every day is getting interesting. You get to know human body, organs, and all the rest, and I love it. I go to libraries. I feel free. Yeah. I feel very free to do whatever I want.
嗯，老实说，我最享受的部分是待在学校。是的，待在学校里做我热爱的事。我喜欢解剖学。那是我的最爱。非常有趣。每一天都变得越来越有趣。你开始了解人体、器官以及所有其他部分，我热爱这一切。我去图书馆。我感到自由。是的，我可以自由地做任何我想做的事。
What he wanted to do was study the thing he'd always wanted to do, be a medical student.
他想做的事就是研究他一直向往的——成为一名医学生。
Were you going to parties? Were you dating?
你去参加聚会吗？你有在约会吗？
No.
没有。
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
Why not?
为什么不呢？
Oh, because there's a saying medical students say, study now and love later.
哦，因为医学生之间有句俗话：现在学习，以后再爱。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Love later. OK.
以后再爱。好吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah.
是的。
How old are you again, Munachi?
穆纳奇，你今年多大了？
I'm 23 now.
我今年23岁了。
Oh, you're 23. OK, OK.
哦，你23岁。好吧，好吧。
Six months after Munachi arrived in Ukraine in January, people in the Nigerian student chat began asking, what's up with the Russians? Munachi's phone buzzed constantly with notifications. He'd sometimes wake up to hundreds of missed messages in the group. Hi, please. Any more info about the war?
穆纳奇一月抵达乌克兰六个月后，群组里的人开始询问：俄罗斯人怎么了？穆纳奇的手机不断弹出通知。他有时醒来会发现群里有几百条未读消息。“嗨，求助，还有关于战争的更多信息吗？”
They're trying to resolve it diplomatically. I don't know if it's true, oh. Not true. True. I don't believe this because if Putin is waiting for marshlands to get frozen, that means he will wait till another winter, and this one is basically over. People just be putting fear in others. Stay safe, though. Damn. I like your analysis, girl. Very apt.
“他们正试图通过外交手段解决。我不知道是不是真的。”“不是真的。”“是真的。”“我不相信，因为如果普京在等沼泽结冰，那意味着他得等到下一个冬天，而这个冬天基本上已经结束了。”“人们只是在散布恐惧。不过，注意安全。”“该死。我喜欢你的分析，女孩。非常中肯。”
All I came here to do was study. I feel your pain, bro-- laughing emoji, laughing emoji. Anybody got malaria drugs? Russians only moved their army closer. Shit didn't happen. Find way, move to Western part of Ukraine, and stay there. The West is already bordered by Russian soldiers through Belarus. That's the north northeast. Oh, well, bro. Everybody done turn geographer.
“我来这里只是为了学习。”“兄弟，我感受到你的痛苦——（大笑表情）。”“有人有抗疟疾药物吗？”“俄罗斯军队只是把兵力部署得更近了。没发生什么。”“找路去乌克兰西部，待在那里。”“西部边境已经有通过白俄罗斯进来的俄罗斯士兵了。那是东北方向。”“哦，好吧，兄弟。每个人都成了地理学家。”
I was telling all the students, whoa. You guys don't need to panic. I don't believe there will be war. We don't need to spread panic. That's just because the school told us not to spread panic. I was telling them to chill. Let's get every information from the school.
我当时告诉所有的学生：“哇，你们不需要恐慌。我不相信会有战争。我们不需要散布恐慌。”那只是因为学校告诉我们不要制造恐慌。我告诉他们冷静点。让我们从学校获取所有信息。
But Munachi says there was almost no information from the school or from the Nigerian embassy. Very quickly, the chat turned from looking for flatmates to trying to escape war. Is it just me that heard those sounds? Yes, just now here in Kyiv. Me, too. I'm hearing the same sounds, oh. Boom, boom. If you see the last one shake my window, my heart first stop. Stay safe, my brothers.
但穆纳奇说学校或尼日利亚大使馆几乎没有提供任何信息。很快，聊天内容就从寻找室友变成了试图逃离战争。“有人听到那些声音了吗？”“是的，基辅这里刚才听到了。”“我也是。我也听到了同样的声音。轰、轰。”“如果最后一个（爆炸）震动了我的窗户，我的心跳先停止了。保重，我的兄弟们。”
Guys, real missile, oh. I'm hearing something from my hostel. Even the ambassador of Nigeria has gone back home. Borders no safe again, oh. Guys, please, which way now? I'm scared. I'm fucking scared. Find your way to Poland and leave. Please, would they allow us to enter Poland? They accept Ukrainians, no? How can we get from Lviv to Kyiv? Everything is down. Fastest way is metro, but to my knowledge, that is also down.
“伙计们，是真的导弹。我从宿舍听到了。连尼日利亚大使都回国了。边境不安全了。伙计们，求你了，现在哪条路能走？我好怕。我真的很怕。”“找到去波兰的路，离开吧。”“请问他们会允许我们进入波兰吗？他们接受乌克兰人，对吧？”“我们怎么从利沃夫（Lviv）到基辅？一切都瘫痪了。”“最快的方法是地铁，但我所知，那个也停了。”
Munachi was reading these messages, but he kept coming up with reasons why he couldn't leave yet. He needed to buy chicken, eggs, tomatoes, apples, juice, milk, and ice cream to fill his fridge. Then he couldn't leave because he had a fridge full of food. He still thought maybe the war would pass. But overall, Munachi says he didn't leave because it would mean abandoning his plan. He wanted to follow the rules, look to an authority for direction.
穆纳奇一直在读这些信息，但他不断寻找理由说服自己还没到不得不离开的时候。他得买鸡肉、鸡蛋、西红柿、苹果、果汁、牛奶和冰淇淋把冰箱塞满。然后他又因为冰箱里装满了食物而不能离开。他仍然觉得战争可能会过去。但总的来说，穆纳奇说他不离开是因为那意味着放弃他的计划。他想遵守规则，听从权威的指导。
Then there was an explosion at Odessa Sea Port, so Munachi took a train to Lviv. Then he went to the platform for the train to Poland, where he found other Africans waiting in the crowd. But the conductor and a police officer were not letting Black people onto the train. He watched as some of them started arguing with the officer blocking the door.
接着敖德萨港发生了爆炸，所以穆纳奇坐火车去了利沃夫。然后他去了去往波兰的站台，发现其他非洲人在人群中等待。但乘务员和警察不让黑人上车。他看着有些人开始和挡在门口的警察争论。
Why? What's going on? Why you not letting us in? This is not good. This is bad. You want us to die? No? The police was like, wait, wait, wait. We are still waiting, like--
“为什么？怎么了？为什么不让我们进去？这不好。这太糟糕了。你们想让我们死吗？不？”警察就像是：“等等，等等。我们还在等。”
Some Africans forced themselves onto the train. But Munachi was told to wait, so he waited until the conductor closed the doors and the train, with empty seats, left without him.
一些非洲人强行挤上了火车。但穆纳奇被告知要等待，于是他一直等到乘务员关上车门，火车在还有空位的情况下离他而去。
Yeah, [SIGHING] and there was a lot of people, so I gave up.
是的，[叹气]，人太多了，所以我放弃了。
He got a taxi with other Africans to drive to the Polish border. But at a certain point, the traffic just stopped moving. So he walked for more than an hour to the crossing and stood in line.
他和几个非洲人搭出租车去往波兰边境。但在某一点，交通彻底停滞了。于是他步行了一个多小时到达关口，排起了队。
So when I get to my town, the border guard told me to go back.
所以当我到达镇上时，边境警卫告诉我回去。
And how long could you have been waiting?
那你可能等了多久？
I've been waiting for maybe two hours. Yeah, and he told me to go back.
我等了可能两个小时。是的，然后他让我回去。
What did you say? How did you react?
你说了什么？你当时是什么反应？
I just go back.
我直接回去了。
You didn't say, why?
你没说“为什么”吗？
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I didn't know what to say, just go back. I was like, I don't want to feel so embarrassed, so I just go back. It was so embarrassing.
我不知道该说什么，只能回去。我当时想，我不希望感到那么尴尬，所以我直接回去了。这太尴尬了。
So when you say that word, embarrassing, what do you mean by it?
所以当你用到“尴尬”这个词时，你是指什么？
For example, in the midst of crowd, others are going in, and you are restricted from going in. People will look at you. I felt like I want to cry. At that point, I feel like I wanted to cry. I feel like, wow, this is it. Wow. I felt so bad, so I said, OK, let me go back. Let me go back.
比如，在人群中，其他人都能进去，而你被限制进入。人们会看着你。我感觉我想哭。那一刻，我觉得我想哭。我心想，哇，就是这样吗？哇。我感觉太糟糕了，所以我说，好吧，让我回去吧。让我回去吧。
At the back of the line, Munachi met some Africans and an Indian man, who said the border guards were going to let them die in Ukraine. The man advised Munachi to try to get someone with a car to take him across. Munachi saw there were long lines of cars passing through. He began hailing them down and asking for a ride, politely, pleadingly. He even offered to pay.
在队伍后方，穆纳奇遇到了一些非洲人和一名印度男子，那人说边境警卫会让他们在乌克兰等死。那人建议穆纳奇试着找个有车的人带他过境。穆纳奇看到有长长的车队通过。他开始拦车并请求搭便车，很有礼貌，近乎哀求。他甚至主动提出付钱。
Yep. I was like, maybe you have a free car-- now, it's your car, I know, but you need to understand. It just happens, you're almost there. Just drive us in or something like that. And we just came in peace.
是的。我想，也许你有空车位——现在，这是你的车，我知道，但你需要理解。这刚刚发生，你都已经到了这里。就开车把我们送进去或者类似这样的事。我们只是和平前来的。
And all of them said, no?
他们都拒绝了吗？
Yeah. All of them said, no. No, no. It felt so bad, and the way they say it, it's like to hurt you. No, no, no-- everyone, the same.
是的。他们都拒绝了。不，不。感觉太糟了，而且他们说出那个词的方式，简直是在伤害你。不、不、不——每个人都一样。
No one wanted to help.
没有人愿意帮忙。
Yeah.
是的。
Was this surprising to you that so many Ukrainians were saying, no, no, no, no?
这么多乌克兰人说“不、不、不”，这对你来说感到惊讶吗？
To me, first, I was thinking it was a very easy something for people to do in this kind of situation. My teachers are Ukrainians and they are so friendly and nice to us. Yeah. I actually thought maybe I'll find my teacher, like, oh, my god, she'll help me or something, or he will help me, something like that. I was--
对我来说，起初，我认为在这种情况下，人们伸出援手是很简单的事。我的老师是乌克兰人，他们对我们非常友好和善良。是的。我其实以为也许我会找到我的老师，像“哦，我的天，她会帮我”或者“他会帮我”之类的。我——
It didn't happen?
没发生这种事？
I was only wishing to see someone that I know, that would just help me. I have to go back, maybe find a place to stay. Then tomorrow I might try again. So I had to walk back again.
我当时只是希望见到一个我认识的人，能帮我一把。我不得不回去，也许找个地方待着。然后明天我再尝试。所以我不得不再次步行回去。
An hour?
一个小时？
Yeah, an hour, again. It was so far. But I was so sad, so it was very easy for me because I was sad.
是的，又要走一小时。太远了。但我太难过了，所以那段路走起来很容易，因为我当时心灰意冷。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Yeah. I was so sad. I wasn't even looking at anybody's face. I hated everyone at that moment. What do I have to do? I don't know what to do. It was already 12:00 in the night. And it was so cold, so cold, like, oh, my god.
是的。我太难过了。我甚至不敢看任何人的脸。那一刻我恨透了每个人。我该怎么办？我不知道该怎么办。当时已经是凌晨12点了。而且太冷了，太冷了，就像，哦，天哪。
Munachi says that on his walk back, he remembers that he stopped feeling like himself. His entire world, everything he thought he knew about Ukraine, was thrown into chaos. Nothing was organized. The Ukrainians he lived among were now treating him like an alien, even an enemy, because he wasn't the right color. Munachi saw himself one way, hardworking, quiet, friendly, and soon realized during the worst moments of his life that others were seeing him in a very different way. The people who wouldn't give him a ride, who wouldn't let him cross the border, to them, his life seemed to be worth less than theirs.
穆纳奇说，在走回来的路上，他记得自己不再感到像自己了。他的整个世界，他以为自己了解的关于乌克兰的一切，都被抛进了混乱之中。没有任何事是有序的。和他住在一起的乌克兰人现在把他视为外人，甚至敌人，只因为他的肤色不对。穆纳奇曾经以一种方式看待自己：勤奋、安静、友好，但很快他在一生中最糟糕的时刻意识到，别人是用一种截然不同的方式看他。那些不愿意搭他一程、不允许他过境的人，对他们而言，他的生命似乎不如他们的值钱。
He finally reaches a hotel, but the clerk says there are no rooms. But this time, Munachi did not just accept what he was told. Munachi calls his cousin in the United States. His cousin gets a friend who speaks Ukrainian to talk to the hotel clerk, and the friend is able to book a room over the phone.
他最终到达了一家酒店，但前台说没有房间了。但这一次，穆纳奇没有接受他所听到的。穆纳奇给在美国的表亲打了电话。他的表亲找了一个会说乌克兰语的朋友和酒店前台交谈，这位朋友通过电话成功预订了一个房间。
So how come there was suddenly a room?
所以为什么突然就有房间了？
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
That is a big question. Well, I gave the lady a very big smile, [LAUGHTER] and like, god, finally, oh, you see.
这是个大问题。嗯，我给了那位女士一个非常灿烂的笑容，[笑声]，就像是，天哪，终于，噢，你看。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The next day, Munachi tried again. He made his way back to the border and could finally cross to Poland. Less than a week later, he moved on to Berlin.
第二天，穆纳奇再次尝试。他成功回到了边境，终于越过关口进入了波兰。不到一周后，他搬到了柏林。
I was in Berlin last month as thousands of refugees from Ukraine came through Central Station and went on to various hostels. The Ukrainians I talked to told me they had no plans. They just wanted their home to be safe again, so they could return as soon as possible.
上个月我还在柏林，当时成千上万的乌克兰难民穿过中央车站前往各个宿舍。我交谈过的乌克兰人告诉我他们没有计划。他们只是想让家园再次变得安全，这样他们就能尽快回去。
But the foreign students, like Munachi, are in a different situation. Ukrainian citizens can get temporary residence in the European Union. Foreign students cannot, even though they're living alongside Ukrainian refugees. They just fled the same war. The students either have to go back to their home countries, or hope that the countries they fled to will allow them to stay and finish the educations they came for.
但像穆纳奇这样的外国学生情况不同。乌克兰公民可以在欧盟获得临时居留权。外国学生则不能，尽管他们和乌克兰难民生活在一起。他们刚刚逃离了同一场战争。学生们要么不得不回到自己的祖国，要么希望他们逃往的国家能允许他们留下来完成学业。
Munachi is currently in his third hostel in Germany. He's been sharing a room with another refugee, learning another new language, and waiting to hear if the German government will let him stay in the country. He and other international students there have until August to get accepted to a German school and prove they have at least 10,000 euros to pay for a year of living costs. Otherwise, they will be required to leave. That's money a lot of students don't have. Munachi is trying to finish up this year's classes online, but it hasn't been easy. He left his school books in Poland. It's still surreal that he's even in this situation.
穆纳奇目前住在德国的第三家宿舍。他一直在和其他难民合租一个房间，学习另一种新语言，并等待德国政府是否会允许他留在该国。他和那里的其他国际学生必须在八月前被德国学校录取，并证明他们至少有1万欧元来支付一年的生活费。否则，他们将被要求离开。这对很多学生来说是一笔他们根本拿不出来的钱。穆纳奇正努力在网上完成今年的课程，但这并不容易。他的教材留在波兰了。他甚至还在这种境地中，这简直太超现实了。
The 1,000 people in the Nigerian students' group chat are now scattered, but people are still posting, checking in on one another, and helping each other figure out their next steps. Please, who is in Poland here? I have my dog stocked in Lviv. It can be sent to you, so you can help me give it to someone coming to Nigeria. Please. I don't want them to die. Hello? Has anyone gotten into Ireland between yesterday and today? Most countries are closing their border now. Anybody know anyone or news from France? Are they deporting people in France? Anybody in Belgium? What's the update, people? Hope you all are safe.
尼日利亚学生群组里的那1000人现在四散各地，但人们仍然在发信息，确认彼此的状态，并帮助对方弄清楚接下来的步骤。“求助，这里有人在波兰吗？我的狗留在利沃夫了。可以寄给你，这样你就能帮我给即将回尼日利亚的人了。拜托。我不希望它们死。”“你好？昨天到今天有人进入爱尔兰了吗？大多数国家现在都在关闭边境。”“有人了解法国的消息吗？法国在遣返人吗？”“有人在比利时吗？大家有什么最新情况？希望你们都安全。”
It's an uneasy limbo these students are in. In order to finish their degrees in Europe, they're signing up for an immediate future of moving from place to place, of starting all over again and again. Here's what Munachi is thinking about.
这些学生处于一种不安的边缘状态。为了在欧洲拿到学位，他们正在签下一种即将到来的、在不同地方漂泊的未来，一次又一次地从头开始。以下是穆纳奇正在考虑的事情。
I asked myself, oh, what does it feel like to be a war student? What if I'm a doctor? What will I be doing in a situation like this if my help is needed, something like that? I don't know if you understand.
我问自己，噢，成为一名“战时学生”是什么感觉？如果我是医生呢？如果我的帮助在这样的情况下是被需要的，那我该做什么？类似这样的。我不确定你是否明白。
I do understand. Munachi is spinning through all the identities he's both imagined for himself and experienced, medical student, doctor, and now, student during wartime. But I noticed there was one word he wasn't using.
我明白。穆纳奇正在经历他所想象的以及他所经历的所有身份的转变：医学生、医生，现在是战时的学生。但我注意到有一个词他一直没用。
Do you feel like a refugee?
你觉得自己像难民吗？
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
These are the feelings I don't want to have.
这些是我不想有的感觉。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Even when you say me as a refugee, I was trying to dodge it, to be honest, yes. My friend told me, well, bro, we are now refugees, like when we came here. I said, no, bro, maybe you, not me.
即使当你把我当作难民时，我也在试图躲避它，老实说，是的。我朋友告诉我：“噢，兄弟，我们现在是难民了，就像我们刚来这里时一样。”我说：“不，兄弟，也许是你，不是我。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But why do you not feel like a refugee?
但你为什么不觉得自己是难民呢？
I don't want to feel like [LAUGHS] a refugee.
我不想觉得自己是[笑]难民。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Right. You don't want to.
对。你不想。
Yeah.
是的。
Right.
对。
But what if I don't want to be a refugee and I want to stay in the country? Ah. Yeah. That's what we cannot control.
但如果我不想成为难民，我想留在该国呢？啊。是的。那是我们无法控制的事情。
These students are different than Ukrainian refugees. They still have homes in Nigeria to which they can return, but going back would be going backwards for them. It would be giving up on how far they've come, so they're fighting to protect their identity as students and as people worthy of respect and dignity. But as Black people displaced by war, even a European one, they have lost all of that.
这些学生与乌克兰难民不同。他们在尼日利亚还有家可以回，但回去对他们来说是倒退。那意味着放弃他们迄今为止所取得的一切，所以他们正在战斗，以保护自己作为学生和作为值得尊重和尊严的人的身份。但作为因战争流离失所的黑人，即使是在欧洲的战争，他们也失去了这一切。
Alexis Okeowo is a staff writer for The New Yorker, where they first wrote about foreign students in Ukraine.
亚历克西斯·奥基沃是《纽约客》的特约撰稿人，他们曾率先报道了乌克兰的外国留学生情况。
Act Three, Alyona and Oleg. OK, so in Russia, lots of people's relationships have become their own personal front lines. Ashley Cleek has been seeing this, talking with a bunch of young Russians who are against the war. Ashley's been reporting on the war for the VICE News Reports podcast. She used to live in Russia.
第三幕，阿廖娜（Alyona）和奥列格（Oleg）。在俄罗斯，许多人的关系已成为他们个人的前线。阿什利·克里克（Ashley Cleek）一直在观察这一点，并与一群反对战争的年轻俄罗斯人交谈。阿什利一直在为《VICE 新闻报道》播客报道战争。她以前住在俄罗斯。
One of the Russians that she'd been talking to about this is Alyona, a 25-year-old protester who lives in Moscow, who's been trying to make sense out of one of her oldest friendships. Because it's so sensitive to speak about the war in Russia right now, we have changed some of the names in this story. Here's Ashley.
她与之谈论过此事的俄罗斯人之一是阿廖娜，一名25岁的莫斯科抗议者，她一直在试图理清她最古老的友谊之一。由于在俄罗斯谈论战争非常敏感，我们更改了故事中部分人物的名字。下面是阿什利。
The friendship Alyona's been struggling with, it's with her friend, Oleg. When I ask her why she's friends with him, she doesn't understand the question. It's just one of the fundamental facts of her life. She and Oleg are friends because they've always been friends. They met when they were seven or eight, in the tiny village hours east of Moscow. It's where Alyona would spend summers with her grandmother. They were outside friends, roaming around in a little pack together.
阿廖娜一直在挣扎的友谊是关于她的朋友奥列格。当我问她为什么和他做朋友时，她不理解这个问题。这只是她生命中的基本事实之一。她和奥列格是朋友，因为他们一直都是朋友。他们在七八岁时相识，在莫斯科东边几个小时车程的一个小村庄里。那是阿廖娜和祖母度过夏天的地方。他们是户外的玩伴，成群结队地一起闲逛。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
So we would steal apples from the neighbors, went out to beat the grass with sticks, rode our bikes a lot, I don't know, tease the goat, stuff like that.
我们会在邻居那儿偷苹果，去用棍子打草，经常骑自行车，不知道，逗弄山羊，诸如此类的事。
So could you explain beating the grass with sticks? I don't totally understand.
你能解释一下“用棍子打草”吗？我不太明白。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
Well, when the grass grows really tall in the field, we would just go out into the field and hit the grass with our sticks.
嗯，当田里的草长得特别高时，我们就会跑到田里，用棍子打草。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
I'm sure that somewhere out in the farms where you are, children do the exact same thing.
我肯定你们那儿的农场外，孩子们也做过完全一样的事。
As they grew up and spread out across the country, Alyona to college, Oleg to the military academy, they stayed really close. Alyona always liked how simple and positive Oleg's outlook was. Nothing seemed to bother him. Whenever Alyona was stressed or angry about something, talking to Oleg would always make it feel like less of a big deal.
随着他们长大并分散到全国各地，阿廖娜上了大学，奥列格进了军事学院，他们依然非常亲密。阿廖娜一直喜欢奥列格简单且积极的人生观。似乎没什么事能困扰他。每当阿廖娜因某事感到压力或愤怒时，和奥列格谈话总能让她觉得那不是什么大不了的事。
When they were teenagers, Russia annexed Crimea. This was 2014. Alyona says she and Oleg and everyone they knew are watching a lot of TV, and she remembers this feeling of euphoria that Russia was doing the right thing, defending ethnic Russians in Crimea. And it had an effect on both of them. Alyona thought about becoming a doctor in the military, and she thinks this is one reason Oleg joined the army.
他们十几岁时，俄罗斯吞并了克里米亚。那是2014年。阿廖娜说，她和奥列格以及他们认识的每个人都在看电视，她记得当时那种俄罗斯正在做正确的事、在捍卫克里米亚族裔俄罗斯人的欣喜感。这对他俩都有影响。阿廖娜曾考虑成为一名军医，她认为这也是奥列格参军的原因之一。
But then in 2019, Alyona went on a trip to Crimea, and it totally changed her mind about what had happened. She was hitchhiking with a friend, talking to a lot of Crimeans, and the story they told was completely different from what she knew. The annexation had been awful.
但到了2019年，阿廖娜去克里米亚旅行，这彻底改变了她对所发生之事的看法。她和朋友搭顺风车，和许多克里米亚人聊天，他们讲述的故事与她所知道的完全不同。吞并行动非常可怕。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
There was this one woman that we hitched a ride with, who took us all the way to Feodosia.
我们搭了一个女人的顺风车，她把我们一路带到了费奥多西亚（Feodosia）。
Alyona's friend asked her about some graffiti he'd seen in Russia back in 2014 that said, Crimea is ours.
阿廖娜的朋友问她关于他在2014年俄罗斯看到的一些涂鸦，上面写着“克里米亚是我们的”。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
And she started literally yelling [LAUGHS] at us, being like, what do you mean, Crimea is yours, when it's ours? It belongs to the people who actually live there. And that made a really big impression on me.
她简直是在对我们大吼[笑]，说：克里米亚是你们的？它属于真正住在那里的人。这给我留下了深刻的印象。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
I came away with the sense that I had made a huge mistake and that I had been thinking really wrongly for a really long time.
我离开时意识到我犯了一个大错，并且很长一段时间以来我的想法都大错特错。
This was the first big crack in what Alyona had believed. When she came back from Crimea, she started going to protests against the government. And hearing about how Putin came to power, about the crimes his government had committed, her entire worldview changed, and she wanted to tell everyone.
这是阿廖娜信仰的第一次重大破裂。从克里米亚回来后，她开始去参加反政府抗议活动。听到普京是如何上台的，关于他的政府所犯下的罪行，她的整个世界观都改变了，她想告诉每个人。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
I was living with the conviction that I had just been living with my eyes closed before that. And now that I had my eyes open, I wanted everyone else in the world to open their eyes, too.
在此之前，我一直带着一种信念活着，觉得我只是闭着眼睛生活。现在我睁开了双眼，我希望世界上其他人也能睁开眼。
Including Oleg, and he listened. He didn't agree with her, but he was nice about it.
包括奥列格，他听了。他不同意她的观点，但他态度很好。
Well, Oleg just said, that's fine. That's your choice.
奥列格只是说，那很好。那是你的选择。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
Oleg's choice was different. He believed the propaganda, what he saw on TV. So he stuck with what the government said. By the way, I reached out to Oleg for this story and didn't hear back. But he knows through Alyona that we're telling it, and he told her he's OK with it. Alyona would talk about her changing politics, and Oleg would disagree, but it never felt like a big deal until this year. In January, Oleg was on leave from the military, and he came through Moscow.
奥列格的选择则不同。他相信宣传，相信电视上看到的内容。所以他坚持政府的说法。顺便提一下，我为这个故事联系了奥列格，但没得到回应。但他通过阿廖娜知道我们在讲述这个故事，他告诉她他不介意。阿廖娜会谈论她变化的政治立场，奥列格会表示不同意，但这从来没觉得是什么大问题，直到今年。一月，奥列格从军队休假，途经莫斯科。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
And he had a few hours before his flight. And we went down to the airline office to get his ticket, and then we hung out at my house, drinking tea and talking. And that was when he told me that there was going to be a war in Ukraine.
他在赶飞机前有几个小时的时间。我们去了航空公司办公室拿票，然后在我家待着，喝茶聊天。就在那时，他告诉我乌克兰将要发生战争。
And I was like, Oleg, please. There's not going to be a war. And I started telling him the stuff from the Steven Pinker book, that global violence is going down, that globally there is less and less crime, there's less murder, less war. That's what all the political scientists say. And he's just like, well, I hope you're right. And that night we said goodbye to each other, and after that, it all began.
我说，奥列格，求你了。不会有战争的。我开始跟他讲斯蒂芬·平克（Steven Pinker）书里的内容，关于全球暴力正在减少，关于全球范围内的犯罪、谋杀和战争越来越少。那是所有政治科学家都这么说的。他只是说，好吧，希望你是对的。那天晚上我们道别了，在那之后，一切开始了。
February 24, Russia invades Ukraine. Alyona calls Oleg, and Oleg says, yes, soldiers are being sent, but he's not on the list. Alyona immediately joins the protest in Moscow.
2月24日，俄罗斯入侵乌克兰。阿廖娜给奥列格打电话，奥列格说，是的，士兵们被派去了，但他不在名单上。阿廖娜立即参加了莫斯科的抗议活动。
[SHOUTING]
[呼喊声]
Alyona is categorically against this war. She decides to get the now-famous phrase, Russian warship, go fuck yourself, tattooed across her ribs. It's her first tattoo. And then in the middle of March, Oleg messages their group chat. Alyona pulls it up to read it to me.
阿廖娜明确反对这场战争。她决定在肋骨上纹上那句如今著名的口号：“俄罗斯战舰，去死吧”。这是她的第一个纹身。三月中旬，奥列格在他们的聊天群里发了信息。阿廖娜打开来读给我听。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
And he said, well, looks like I'm actually leaving. And I'm only going to have a dumb phone with me when I get there, so I'm not going to be able to send you anything over telegram. I love you all. Goodbye.
他说，嗯，看起来我真的要走了。我到那儿后只能用一部老人机，所以我无法通过电报（Telegram）发任何东西给你们。我爱你们。再见。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
And our friend was like, where exactly are they sending you? And he said, they're sending me to the hot zone.
我们的朋友问：他们到底要把你派到哪里去？他说，他们要派我去热点地区。
Alyona writes back, we all love you, then calls him. She wants to know exactly where he's going and what he'll be doing.
阿廖娜回道，我们都爱你，然后给他打电话。她想知道他要去哪，要去做什么。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
And then he told me that he was probably going to go to Rostov or maybe even somewhere closer, just to pick up the bodies of the dead, the casualties.
然后他告诉我他可能要回罗斯托夫，甚至更近的地方，只是去收敛死者遗体，那些伤亡者。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
I was like, promise me that you're not going to go fight in this war. For me, him going to get the bodies was OK, as long as he didn't go fight. And he said, I can't promise you that.
我说，答应我，你不会去这场战争中战斗。对我来说，他去收尸是可以接受的，只要他不战斗。他说，我不能答应你。
How did you feel? How was that for you?
你当时感觉如何？那对你来说是什么样的？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
Well, I just completely freaked out. I was just yelling at him. I don't even remember what I was yelling, and I was just screaming into my phone, and he was completely silent.
嗯，我彻底崩溃了。我只是对他大吼大叫。我甚至不记得我在喊什么，我只是对着电话尖叫，而他完全沉默。
Alyona tries to convince him not to go, that since it's not an officially declared war, he can defect without getting in trouble. She's looking for a way out for him, but he doesn't want one. She remembers yelling that she was going to come to his army base and break all his fingers.
阿廖娜试着说服他不要去，既然这不是正式宣战，他可以逃兵而不会惹上麻烦。她在为他寻找退路，但他不想要。她记得当时喊着说要去他的军营折断他的所有手指。
By the end of the call, she's calmed down, accepted that this is what's happening. She can't change it. But that evening, as the reality of what's happening settles in, that there's no way Oleg can go to war and not harm someone, Alyona swings back into a state of impotence and rage.
通话结束时，她冷静下来，接受了这就是现实。她无法改变它。但那天晚上，当现实尘埃落定，当她意识到奥列格不可能去打仗而不伤害别人时，阿廖娜再次陷入了无能为力和愤怒的状态。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
I got so wasted that night at a bar that I was probably screaming loud enough for everybody in the bar to hear me that my friend was going to go fight in this war, and it would be better if he just died in it.
那晚在酒吧我喝得烂醉，可能大声喊到酒吧里的每个人都听见了，说我朋友要去打这场战争，他死在里面更好。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
Because if he doesn't die, he'll come back, and I'll know that he's a murderer.
因为如果他不死，他回来后，我就会知道他是个杀人犯。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
That he's a criminal.
他是个罪犯。
Alyona's not sure if she ever wants to talk to him again.
阿廖娜不确定自己是否还想和他说话。
So many people I've talked to in Russia are going through something like this right now, having their fundamental relationships get ripped up by this war. Several of my friends no longer talk to their parents. One of my friends, whose response to this war was to threaten to burn his passport, his father called him a Nazi. And he doesn't know how he'll get over that.
我在俄罗斯谈话的许多人现在都经历着这样的事，他们的基本关系被这场战争撕裂。我的几个朋友不再和父母说话。我的一个朋友，他对战争的回应是威胁要烧掉护照，他父亲叫他纳粹。他不知道如何走出来。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
I was coming home from work, and I was going up the escalator in the subway.
我当时下班回家，正搭地铁的自动扶梯上去。
I talked to Alyona a few weeks later.
几周后，我再次和阿廖娜交谈。
And I got a phone call, and I didn't even suspect who it was. And I was already kind of pissed off because I actually hate it when people call me.
我接到了一个电话，甚至没猜到是谁打的。我当时已经有点火了，因为我真的很讨厌别人给我打电话。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
And then when I took out my phone and I saw that it was Oleg, I mean, I don't even have the words to describe what I felt.
当我拿出手机看到是奥列格时，天哪，我甚至找不到词来形容我的感受。
This was two weeks after he'd left, and Alyona's relieved just to hear his voice again. All that anger that she'd felt so intensely towards him, in that moment, disappeared.
那是他离开两周后，阿廖娜仅仅是再次听到他的声音就感到宽慰。她对他感受到的所有强烈的愤怒在那一刻消失了。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
I got up to the top of the escalator and I was just pacing around in the subway station, asking him totally banal questions, like, what are you eating, what are you drinking, how is the weather, just completely silly things.
我走到自动扶梯顶端，在地铁站里来回踱步，问他一些完全平庸的问题，比如你吃什么、喝什么、天气怎么样，完全是些傻问题。
How did he answer? What did he tell you?
他是怎么回答的？他告诉了你什么？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
When I asked him how he was sleeping, he told me he wasn't sleeping well. And I started telling him stuff like, oh, man, sleep is so important for your mental health, and you have to try to sleep well. And he just laughed at me and he was like, can you imagine how hard it is to sleep in Ukraine right now?
当我问他睡得怎么样时，他告诉我他睡得不好。我开始告诉他一些东西，比如：噢，伙计，睡眠对心理健康很重要，你得试着睡好。他只是笑了笑，说：你能想象在乌克兰现在睡个觉有多难吗？
After that call, they keep texting. Eventually, his unit is moved from somewhere around Kyiv to Belarus. And there, he's more free to talk. They video-chat every few days. During one call, Oleg shares these details about the war and a crime he's heard a Russian soldier has committed. Suddenly, their calls cut off. After that, they decide they shouldn't talk about the war because they're probably being monitored. So they stick to basic stuff, food, weather.
在那通电话后，他们继续发着短信。最终，他的部队从基辅周围被调往白俄罗斯。在那里，他可以更自由地谈话。他们每隔几天就视频通话一次。在一次通话中，奥列格分享了关于战争的细节以及他听说的俄罗斯士兵犯下的罪行。突然，他们的通话中断了。在那之后，他们决定不谈论战争，因为他们可能被监视了。所以他们保持谈论基本内容，食物、天气。
Talking to Alyona these past weeks has been like watching a pendulum swing back and forth. She started off with such intense feelings of fury and helplessness. She once cried on a call. But now she's swinging less. All the feelings are still there. They're just smaller. On her way to work, she does these small protests. She ties green ribbons in tree branches. She writes, No War, in black Sharpie at her benches. And she still chats with her friend, a Russian soldier.
过去几周和阿廖娜谈话，就像看着一个来回摆动的钟摆。她开始时带有强烈的愤怒和无助感。有一次在通话中她甚至哭了。但现在摆动变小了。所有的感觉依然存在，只是变小了。在去工作的路上，她会进行小小的抗议。她在树枝上系上绿丝带。她在长椅上用黑色记号笔写下“不要战争”。她仍然和她身为俄罗斯士兵的朋友聊天。
And then the news from Bucha comes out. Hundreds of civilians have been killed. The photos, as many of you know, are awful. There are dead bodies in the streets, in gardens, fallen from bicycles. For Alyona, there was one picture in particular that made her whole body turn cold. It was of a woman's hand, lifeless. Alyona remembered the perfect manicure, one nail painted with a tiny heart.
然后关于布查（Bucha）的消息传了出来。数百名平民被杀。正如你们许多人知道的那样，那些照片太可怕了。街上、花园里有尸体，有人从自行车上跌落。对阿廖娜来说，有一张照片尤其让她全身冰凉。那是一只女人的手，毫无生气。阿廖娜记得那个完美的指甲，有一个指甲上画着一颗微小的爱心。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
What was going through their heads, that they could have done that?
他们脑子里在想什么，才会做那种事？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
It's unbearable to even think about how you're the same species as people who are capable of doing something like that.
想到你竟然和能做出这种事的人属于同一个物种，真是难以忍受。
And when you saw it, when you heard about it, did you think about Oleg?
当你看到它，当你听到这件事时，你想到了奥列格吗？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
It's just really hard to put into words.
这真的很难用语言表达。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
After Bucha, Alyona says, it was harder to talk to Oleg. She asked him if he was part of anything like that. He said, no. But then, he denied it was even happening. He tried to convince her that it was all a lie.
布查事件后，阿廖娜说，和奥列格交谈变得更难了。她问他是否参与了类似的事。他说没有。但随后，他否认那件事发生过。他试着说服她，那一切都是谎言。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
When I asked Oleg about Bucha, he immediately was telling me that this was a false flag, that the Ukrainian army had done it themselves, just kept saying and is still saying that Bucha was faked and that nothing like that happened where he was, either.
当我问奥列格关于布查的事时，他立刻告诉我这是一个“假旗行动”（false flag），说是乌克兰军队自己干的，只是不断地说，现在还在说布查是伪造的，而且他说他待过的地方也没发生过那种事。
And this, it infuriated Alyona. He had recently told her how he had heard of a soldier committing crimes against civilians, and now here he was, parroting the government's propaganda. That thing she used to love about him, his refusal to be bothered by anything, it now made her sick.
这让阿廖娜愤怒到了极点。他最近才告诉她，他听说了有士兵对平民犯罪，而现在他却在这里鹦鹉学舌地重复政府的宣传。她以前爱他的那种“对什么事都不愿受到困扰”的态度，现在让她感到恶心。
As Alyona tells me about this conversation, though, I could hear her softening, giving him the benefit of the doubt, the benefit of friendship. Part of her would really like to imagine that maybe Oleg doesn't even believe what he's saying to her, but that he has to say it.
然而，当阿廖娜向我讲述这段对话时，我能听到她的心软了下来，给了他一些怀疑的好处，给了友情一些空间。她内心的一部分真的很想想象：也许奥列格甚至不相信他对她说的话，但他不得不说。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
It's very possible that he's just telling me what they tell him to tell people.
很有可能他只是在告诉她，上面让他们告诉别人什么。
Their friendship used to be so easy. Now it has the weight of a war attached to it. I don't know if it survives this. It seems like, despite all of Alyona's efforts, there's been an irreversible change. But Alyona is pushing back against it. She's holding onto this imaginary future where Oleg will come back a different person, that he'll grow to see things more her way, less like that of a dutiful, party-line soldier, maybe go to therapy.
他们的友谊曾经那么轻松。现在它附着了战争的重担。我不知道它能否挺过这一关。看来，尽管阿廖娜付出了所有努力，但已发生了不可逆转的变化。但阿廖娜正在回击。她坚持着一个想象中的未来：奥列格会带着不同的面貌回来，他会渐渐开始以她的方式看待事物，而不是像一个唯命是从的党内士兵，也许还会去做心理治疗。
And that's what I'm invested in, and that's why I'm continuing my relationship with him.
而这就是我所投入的，这就是我继续和他维持关系的原因。
And what if he doesn't become that kind of person?
如果他没有变成那样的人呢？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语对话]
Well, I am not going to give up, or let me put it like this. If I start thinking about how the war is not going to end, how Russia's not going to retreat from Ukraine, how people are never going to face up to what they've done and acknowledge their mistakes, I'm not going to be able to function. And so I can't think that way.
嗯，我不会放弃，或者让我这样说吧：如果我开始思考战争不会结束，俄罗斯不会从乌克兰撤军，人们永远不会直面他们所做的事并承认错误，我将无法生活下去。所以我不能那样想。
Alyona just got news that Oleg's been sent back into Ukraine. When he returns from the war, though, she's determined to stay his friend. And then she hopes someday, maybe in 20 or 30 years, they'll finally be able to talk about what really happened in the war.
阿廖娜刚刚收到消息，奥列格被送回了乌克兰。不过当他从战争中回来时，她决心继续做他的朋友。然后她希望有一天，也许在20或30年后，他们最终能谈论战争中到底发生了什么。
Ashley Cleek. She's a producer for VICE News Reports, which is a weekly podcast by VICE Audio, with lots of reporting on the war in Ukraine that dives deeply into people's personal stories.
阿什利·克里克。她是《VICE 新闻报道》的制作人，该节目是 VICE Audio 每周播出的播客，有着大量深入剖析人们个人故事的乌克兰战争报道。
[MUSIC - "WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE" BY SOLANGE]
[音乐 - Solange 的《WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE》]
Well, our program was produced today by our executive editor, Emanuele Berry, and by Diane Wu. People who put together today's show include Chris Benderev, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Andrea López Cruzado, Aviva DeKornfeld, Chana Joffe-Walt, Rudy Lee, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Alix Spiegel, Robyn Semien, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney.
好了，我们今天的节目由执行编辑 Emanuele Berry 和 Diane Wu 制作。参与制作今日节目的还有 Chris Benderev, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Andrea López Cruzado, Aviva DeKornfeld, Chana Joffe-Walt, Rudy Lee, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Alix Spiegel, Robyn Semien, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala 以及 Matt Tierney。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Russian interpretation by Bela Shayevich. Editing help from Bethel Habte. Special thanks today to Sam Greenspan, Sam Eagan, and Kate Osbourne at the VICE News Reports podcast, where you can hear more of Katia's audio diaries from Kyiv that we heard at the beginning of the show. Katia's dad, Volodymyr, as she talked about in the excerpts we played, died last Monday.
我们的总编辑是 Sarah Abdurrahman。高级编辑是 David Kestenbaum。俄语口译由 Bela Shayevich 提供。Bethel Habte 提供了编辑帮助。特别感谢今天 VICE 新闻报道播客的 Sam Greenspan, Sam Eagan 和 Kate Osbourne，在那里您可以听到更多我们在节目开头播放的卡蒂亚在基辅录制的音频日记。正如我们在节目片段中提到的，卡蒂亚的父亲弗拉基米尔（Volodymyr）已于上周一去世。
Thanks also today to Ibe Elvis Chigaemezu, Egwim Chioma Benjamin, Luisa Emmi Beck, Kevin Caners, Katharina Eggmann, Dana Ballout, Helen Davidson, Anthony Kuhn, and Angela Mosher-Salazar. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. There's lists of favorite programs. There's tons of other stuff there. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org.
还要感谢今天的 Ibe Elvis Chigaemezu, Egwim Chioma Benjamin, Luisa Emmi Beck, Kevin Caners, Katharina Eggmann, Dana Ballout, Helen Davidson, Anthony Kuhn 以及 Angela Mosher-Salazar。我们的网站是 ThisAmericanLife.org，您可以完全免费地在线收听我们超过750集的档案。还有视频。有最喜欢的节目列表。上面还有大量其他内容。再次强调，ThisAmericanLife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Most nights, he just sits in his easy chair, sipping a White Claw, watching his favorite, Ali Wong. Now and then, he talks to the television.
《美国生活》通过 PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人 Torey Malatia 先生。大多数晚上，他只是坐在舒适的椅子上，喝着 White Claw，看他最喜欢的 Ali Wong。偶尔，他会和电视说话。
Damn. I like your analysis, girl. Very apt.
“该死。我喜欢你的分析，女孩。非常中肯。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE" BY SOLANGE]
[音乐 - Solange 的《WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE》]